i've been thinking about tom nicholls
writes about a death of expertise we
have a death of expertise you mentioned
the pandemic we would have been so much
better off in the beginning if people
said look we don't know we really don't
know yet that's literally all they had
to say we're doing our best we don't
know
they did
but the problem is two things happened
one
lots of us said we don't know let's
figure out what we can and the natural
process whereby a model of the virus a
model of the epidemic a model of
people's behavior began to emerge that
thing was actually doing beautifully
but
handed down from on high was then a set
of prescriptions where we were told what
the virus was where it came from how it
behaved what we needed to do and all of
it was wrong yeah so so
you know i'm always amazed when people
ask me about this like what do you think
about i mean how the [ __ ] do i know i
have no
not only
do i have nothing substantive to add i
have in high school no offense but i
haven't had a high school biology class
since i was in high school and high
school was my last point yeah
interactive biology i have no no i have
no so like nobody should listen to me no
wrong really why tell me why anybody
should listen to me well it's not that
they should listen to you as an
authority on the biology but let's just
say
we were all told
that the covid vaccines were
highly effective and that what was
necessary in order to control the
disease was our compliance
right
correct
correct i wouldn't use the word
compliance but that we all should we all
accepted it we could all accept and i
would say in
given yeah a high quality vaccine that
was safe enough that yeah we should all
do our part and get it but
anybody and i got it right away i got it
for a multitude of reasons i i told you
i have crohn's disease it's an
autoimmune disease so i got it right
away and boosted et cetera right well
maybe we'll come back to what happened
to you okay nonetheless my point would
be if you're told if you are assured
this vaccine is very effective at
preventing people from contracting and
transmitting covid and then
you find out two months later well it's
not very effective at preventing people
from contracting
uh or transmitting covet and then it
turns out it's not effective at all and
it turns out places where essentially
everyone took it haven't controlled the
virus and now we have a wave of the
virus that is running rampant through
the vaccinated population then the
answer is well
i don't know anything about how
i'm now not speaking for me i'm speaking
for a lay person but i don't know
anything about how viruses function or
how vaccines create immunity but i can
tell that what i was told yeah didn't
turn out to be right and i can tell that
the people who i was told were
distributing misinformation turned out
to be much more predictive right that is
something anybody can see
yeah so i guess in that situation
and i'm even hesitant to have these
conversations because i know so little
about
i don't want to even say the biology the
medical aspect the epidemiological
aspect of it
um
yeah i think
i think we can say
that if we were told something and it
turned out to be false
that that's a reason for suspicion
it's probably a reason for suspicion
it doesn't mean that the things that
those that the people who told us
and were wrong are wrong about
everything it does mean that people
particularly in
i this is my inference from that people
in a public setting
should be more humble about what they
claim to know particularly when it comes
to public health sure but i would say
what we have is a very powerful public
health apparatus that told us many
things essentially all of them turned
out to be false
you had a habit i can't that i can't
speak to you well yeah you can't but if
you looked at it you could you know you
you're as capable as anyone of going
back to the history and looking at who
said what when and then seeing what
happened
right and if it is true that the
heterodox community of doctors and
scientists who were discussing this were
much more predictive than the public
health authorities and that in fact the
public health authorities
partnered with the uh social media
platforms and demonized the heterodox
scientists and doctors and in fact
ruthlessly stigmatize them which goes on
to this day then that would tell you
something it's odd that the people who
had less predictive power were in a
position to destroy the careers of
people who were more predictable so
you'd have to yeah so what you'd have to
do correct what you have to do is you
have to break down down those claims and
see which was true and it was false
absolutely
right well here's the problem nobody's
doing that but somebody should right
what this really requires is a top-notch
old-school journalist to go back and say
well
we're now years in let's figure out who
was right and let's figure out what
happened to them right i i hope that
happens that would seem to me to be most
most reasonable not only most reasonable
but incredibly pressing
yeah neil ferguson writes about that in
doom this idea that you you you how do
we predict prevent the next pandemic you
know what do we do what kind of things
should we thinking about what kind of
infrastructure should we have
yeah yeah
so anyway um
let's put it this way this we are not
brand new to the question of you know
how to figure out what's true right
there are thousands of years of track
record on
uh sorting out claims and figuring out
what's accurate
[Music]
you